Identify 15/8, or 15
over 8, as a proper
or an improper fraction.
So this is actually
just a good review
of proper and
improper fractions.
And there's a pretty easy
way to identify them.
You have a proper fraction if
your numerator-- so this right
here is your numerator,
the number on top.
Let me just label them,
numerator and denominator.
You have a proper
fraction if your numerator
is less than your denominator.
And if you don't have
a proper fraction,
you have an improper fraction.
So your improper fraction
is if your numerator
is greater than or equal
to your denominator.
And over here, actually, all
the numbers are positive.
But if you had some
negative numbers here,
then you would actually say the
absolute value of the numerator
is less than the absolute
value of the denominator,
for a proper fraction.
And the absolute
value of the numerator
is greater than or equal
to the absolute value
of the denominator for
an improper fraction.
So let me just write
that down, just
to be a little bit
more particular here,
because we could have negative
numbers in either the numerator
or the denominator.
Anyway, let's go
back to this problem.
15 is clearly greater
than or equal to 8.
So 15 is greater
than or equal to 8,
so we are dealing with
an improper fraction.